herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren wir nähern uns dem ende
einer legislaturperiode die anders
verlaufen als wir uns das alle dachten
wir halten als regierung sie als
abgeordnete und natürlich die
bürgerinnen und bürger wir haben alle
mit der größten herausforderung unseres
wiedervereinigten dann das zu tun gehabt
wir haben jetzt eine sehr sehr lange
zeit zeit miteinander gegen die korona
krise gekämpft haben gemeinsam gekämpft
um die gesundheit der bürgerinnen und
bürger gekämpft damit arbeitsplätze und
unternehmen durch diese krise kommen und
damit ein aufschwung kommt damit es auch
in zukunft noch arbeitsplätze gibt und
es ist uns gelungen so weit zu kommen
wie wir heute gekommen sind weil wir
zusammengehalten haben
[Applaus]
wir haben zusammengehalten als ganzes
land aber er den zusammenhang verstehe
ich jetzt persönlich nicht ganz so diese
angst schüren damit es auch in zukunft
noch arbeitsplätze gibt und dann wenn
vollmer thema gesprochen wird die korona
maßnahmen haben arbeitsplätze gekostet
es wurden menschen eigentlich dich und
mich war das zwangsurlaub geschickt sie
wurden in kurzarbeit geschickt die
restaurants dürfen offen und dann jetzt
schon wieder die panikmache noch
arbeitsplätze gibt und wie gut durch die
krise gekommen sind ist also für mich
wie eine entschuldigung angebracht
[Applaus]
jetzt haben wir jetzt haben wir eine
situation die sehr viel anders ist viele
bürgerinnen und bürger sind geimpft das
ist ein anderer zustand als wir im
letzten jahr hatten und deshalb dürfen
wir hoffen dass der herbst und winter
der jetzt vor uns liegt anders verläuft
als der herbst und winter den wir hinter
uns hatten und für mich gibt es deshalb
auch ein paar dinge die man hier klar
aussprechen kann wir werden keinen neuen
lockdown haben und wir können die kinder
die schüler mitschüler auch wieder im
präsenzunterricht in den schulen haben
[Applaus]
hochspannend olaf scholz ist nicht
abgeordnete des bundestags und er
spricht quasi als bundeskanzler während
angela merkel abgeordnete so noch als
abgeordneten gesprochen olaf scholz hält
hier die rede wie angela merkel nicht
geeignet und positioniert sich in einem
wasser sagt ganz klar als staatsmann als
vater des landes als derjenige der über
die großen linien spricht er spricht im
bundestag wie ein bundeskanzler
und auch das finde ich gerne sagen wir
müssen dafür sorge tragen dass wir sie
überzeugen indem wir das machen
lockergelassen auch mit witzen über die
auf vielen veranstaltungen gelacht wird
wenn einige nicht lachen wollen und
darüber sich aufregen hat das vielleicht
etwas damit zu tun dass sie beim blick
auf ihre umfragewerte wenig zu lachen
haben
und deshalb auch mein wunsch
ja nichts music deutschland offen im
moment mehr als olaf scholz wort vom
versuch scania verteidigt ist hier ganz
klar er sagt das war ein witz die über
den manche leute nicht lachen können
vermutlich als ich eure wahlkampf und
umfragewerten ich lache können damit
meint er natürlich klar dass armin
laschet wir sehen olaf scholz geht vom
kanzler modus gibt es auch im bundestag
werden in den modus attacke in den modus
wo sich angriff in den modus weltcup das
gilt für masken in bahnen und bussen das
gilt selbstverständlich auch darauf dass
wir in ein restaurant geht oder in eine
bestimmte einrichtung genesen geimpft
oder getestet sein muss alles zumutbare
beschränkung die sind keine
unvertretbaren und und rechts
einschränkungen wie die afg uns immer
sei es sind die maßnahmen zur sicherheit
der bürgerinnen und bürger und sie
werden zusammen mit dem impf und durch
diese tiere
dass wir so weit gekommen sind und dass
wir auch
zumutbaren beschränkungen darüber kann
man diskutieren was ich aber ehrlich
gesagt von olaf scholz verliert daneben
ist direkt zu sagen die ard gerne sagen
weil damit sagen sie eigentlich dass
jeder bürger der etwas gegen diese für
mich sind es auch zumutungen ehrlich
gesagt weil er was dagegen hat drehen
bringt ja eigentlich direkt in die afg
ecke man muss natürlich schon darüber
diskutiert genesen getestet geimpft ist
was richtig aber falsch wenn man die
tests selbst heraus zu nehmen in dieser
krise zu retten deshalb ist es richtig
dass wir mit diesem großen einsatz jetzt
sehen der aufschwung kommt wir wachsen
aus der krise raus aber deshalb ist auch
klar zu sagen wir werden mit dem
wachstum die finanziellen
verpflichtungen die aus dieser krise
erwachsen sind auch wieder bewältigen
können das ist uns nach der letzten
wirtschaftskrise gelungen das wird uns
nach dieser wieder geworden
wachstum ist das entscheidende aber was
nicht funktioniert das will ich gerne
ausdrücklich sagen ist jetzt wenn in
dieser situation einige in diesem haus
vorschlagen dass leute die so viel
verdienen wie ein bundesminister oder
ein bundestagsabgeordneter oder noch
noch noch viel mehr dringend mal eine
steuersenkung brauchen 30 milliarden
euro steuersenkungen die sie vorschlagen
für spitzenverdiener und unternehmen mit
riesigen gewinnen sind in dieser
situation
unfinanzierbar und völlig aus der zeit
gefallen und kein beweis für den
zusammenhalt dieser gesellschaft
das muss man also anders machen wenn wir
zusammenhalten wollen so wie wir es
jetzt auch tun bei der bekämpfung der
folgen der flut die uns in den letzten
tagen so sehr bedrückt hat das ist eine
große herausforderung für unser land und
auch dort gilt wieder die eine
erkenntnis die für unsere gute zukunft
wichtig ist wir werden solchen krisen
und herausforderungen nur bewältigen
können wenn wir zusammenhalten wenn wir
das gemeinsam durchstehen wollen wenn
niemand mit seinen problemen alleine
gelassen wird jetzt nicht die
bürgerinnen und bürger deren häuser
zerstört worden sind jetzt nicht die
dörfer und städte die zerstört worden
sind jetzt nicht die länder die aldi
infrastrukturen wieder aufbauen müssen
wir müssen als land zusammenhalten wir
tun das und ist richtig dass der
bundestag dazu die notwendigen mittel
jetzt bewilligt
zusammenhalt das ist auch das was wir im
blick haben müssen wenn wir über die
zukunft unserer gesellschaft diskutieren
und deshalb will ich über drei garantien
reden die mir ganz ganz wichtig sind für
den zusammenhalt den wir hier zu lande
brauchen die erste garantie ist eine die
für die jungen leute wichtig ist für die
kinder für die hier aufwachsen ich finde
in einem so reichen land wie deutschland
darf es nicht so sein dass kinder in
armut aufwachsen wir müssen etwas tun um
sie für eine gute zukunft zu
unterstützen deshalb setze ich mich
dafür ein dass wir das kindergeld
weiterentwickeln dass wir eine
grundsicherung bekommt die armut für
kinder verhindert das muss in der
nächsten legislaturperiode gelingen
und wir müssen dafür sorge tragen dass
sie gut aufwachsen können deshalb war
das richtig dass wir den weg
eingeschlagen haben mit dem gute kita
gesetz deshalb war es richtig dass wir
den ausbau der kinderbetreuung
vorangetrieben haben und deshalb ist es
richtig dass wir jetzt vier jahre darum
gestritten haben und heute ist
hoffentlich vollenden dass es auch
ganztagsangebote in den schulen gibt
deutschland muss ein land werden das
besser ist zu seinen kindern mit einer
guten kinderbetreuung mit einem
ganztagsangebot in den schulen und das
ist etwas was wir gemeinsam erreichen
müssen bund länder und gemeinden
zusammen
wir müssen dafür sorge tragen dass die
jungen leute berufliche perspektiven
haben und deshalb ist es wichtig dass
wir dafür sorgen dass diejenigen die
studieren wollen bessere möglichkeiten
haben mit einer besseren
ausbildungsförderung aber noch viel
wichtiger ist dass wir uns um die
wichtigste ausbildung in deutschland
kümmern das ist nämlich unverändert die
berufsausbildung wir müssen dafür sorge
tragen dass jeder der nach der neunten
oder zehnten klasse die schule verlässt
auch eine gute perspektive auch in der
ausbildung hat eine garantie ein
ausbildungsplatz zu finden platzangst
ein bisschen den faden verloren was die
drei forderungen von olaf scholz und das
hat er dann am ende nicht mehr so ganz
genau strukturiert aber insgesamt muss
man sagen für olaf scholz verhältnisse
eine geradezu heißblütige eine
empathische rede die vermutlich gut
ankommen mit eine klassische
wahlkampfrede mit klassischer
programmatik in der er sich als vater
der nation positioniert bisher für olaf
scholz dieser auftritt und mit
sicherheit einer vollends politik als
gemeinwesen einsetzen müssen und die
tatsache dass es in deutschland nicht
genug wohnungen geben die tatsache dass
es so ist dass die wohnungsmieten durch
die decke schießen das hat etwas damit
zu tun dass in den letzten jahren in
deutschland nicht gebaut worden genug
gebaut worden ist und wir müssen dafür
sorge tragen dass mehr wohnungen in
deutschland errichtet werden
ich habe mir das nochmal angeschaut
1933 alles großartig an kinder sollen
besser aufwachsen und mehr bildung
wohnungen aber wie will der schweiz ist
eigentlich alles finanzieren nicht stört
bislang es wird immer die ganzen
besprechen werden betont und was man
will und das stimmt ja auch fast sie
dazu aber wie will er das finanzhaus
herkommen gleich auch mal auf die
wirtschaftlich erreichen ohne damit
aufzuhören
400.000 wohnungen bauen und 100000
geförderte wohnungen damit auch
diejenigen mit wenig geld sich eine
wohnung mieten
und weil das nicht auch von einem tag
auf den anderen geht weil das eine
anstrengende und viele viele jahre die
ganze zeit des nächsten jahrzehnts
beschäftigen wird sage ich ausdrücklich
wir müssen zwischendurch auch dafür
sorgen dass die mieten nicht durch die
decke schießen weil es zu wenig
wohnungen gibt und deshalb brauchen wir
ein starkes mieter schutzrechte da
brauchen wir eine begrenzung der pid
preissteigerung bei neuvermietung und
deshalb brauchen wir ein moratorium für
die meisten spiele in deutschland
ordnungspolitisch klarer widerspruch
dabei olaf scholz muss man sagen
einerseits beklagt er die zu hohen
mieten zu wenig wohnraum andererseits
villa die klassische sozialistische
politik sei den leuten ganz massiv
eingreifen was nie zu mehr wohnraum und
damit niedrigeren ist wird sondern immer
schon weniger wohnraum und damit höhere
mieten da hat er urlaub scheuchen alte
sozialistisches wirtschaftspolitik
gespenst aus der mottenkiste rausgeholt
er das hier in berlin schon auf
katastrophale weise gescheitert ist und
übrigens vom bundesverfassungsgericht
abgewatscht worden ist und eine
berufsausbildung beginnt derjenige oder
diejenige hat fünf jahrzehnte arbeit vor
sich die ganze zeit müssen beiträge
gezahlt werden und in der ganzen zeit
muss er oder sie sich darauf verlassen
können dass das hinterher auch etwas
bringt für die rente deshalb müssen
klare aussagen her kein anstieg des
renteneintrittsalters und ein stabiles
rentenniveau das muss unsere
gesellschaft den bürgern dieses landes
garantieren
das geht auch das geht auch und ich will
gerne sagen dass ich sehr aufgeregt und
entwickeln wenn all die experten
experten die uns in den 90er jahren so
viele dinge gesagt haben sich jetzt
wieder melden sie haben uns damals
gesagt wir würden jetzt zu dieser zeit
viel höhere beiträge zahlen als für
jetzt zahlen und sie haben uns damals
gesagt es würde jetzt viel weniger
arbeitnehmern arbeitnehmer geben als zu
der zeit tatsächlich zahlen wir
geringere beiträge zur
rentenversicherung als zurzeit von
helmut kohl und tatsächlich ist es so
dass millionen zusätzliche arbeitnehmern
und aber die arbeitskraft ihre
arbeitskräfte einsetzten geld verdienen
und auch die rentenfinanzen starb ließ
ich würde eher schweiz die gerne mal in
den wwe unterricht stecken aus zwei
gründen ist ja nicht so als hätte der
staat zu wenig geld die einnahmen sind
ja da wir brauchen nicht mehr steuern
brauchen auch nicht mehr rentenbeiträge
sondern wir brauchen gute unternehmer
der staat ist einfach furchtbar
schlechter unternehmer wenn wir nicht so
viel geld an dauernd verlieren würden
wäre auch geld für andere dinge dass und
deswegen würde ich gerne und ja wwl
unterricht vorschlagen dabei muss die
antwort doch klar sein es geht um
beschäftigung wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass wir ein hohes beschäftigungsniveau
in deutschland haben und wenn es uns
gelänge auch nur besser zu werden so wie
wir das besser zu werden indem der art
und weise wie das in schweden der fall
ist was frauenerwerbstätigkeit betrifft
dann hätten wir schon stabile renten und
wenn es uns gelingen würde das eine
55-jährige oder ein 58-jähriger die
ihren arbeitsplatz verlieren sicher
annehmen können dass sie erneut eine
gute beschäftigung finden würden dann
hätten wir stabile und das ist die
aufgabe die wir anpacken und die gt herr
minister die kollegen von storch würde
ich in der inzwischen fragen stellen
gestatten sie es
der kleiner feiner aber spektakulären
moment in der parlamentarischen
demokratie gerade die abgeordnete von
storch von der fdp will eine
zwischenfrage stellen was ich
normalerweise immer gemütlich gestaltet
wird von den abgeordneten so sein olaf
scholz er mit seiner über die übrigen
südlichen hamburger granit gene in
richtung von bundestagspräsident
wolfgang sollen also die schreie seiner
redezeit für die auf touren mit den
rentenfinanzen wenn wir das als gesamtes
land solidarisch angehen und ich finde
deshalb ist das eine wichtige aussage
die viele verdient haben ich jedenfalls
werde mich dafür einsetzen dass wir
diese drei garantien für unsere zukunft
geben und dann müssen wir uns den beiden
großen herausforderungen zuwenden die
jetzt vor uns liegen wenn wir uns auf
die 20er jahre zu bewegen die jetzt
begonnen haben die nächsten zehn jahre
werden entscheidend sein für die zukunft
unseres landes die weichen die wir jetzt
fall stellen die werden dazu führen dass
wir nicht es schaffen die großen
herausforderung zu bewältigen wenn wir
es falsch machen kann uns dass wohlstand
und arbeitsplätze kosten wenn wir es
richtig machen werden wir eine bessere
zukunft haben und deshalb zwei dinge die
mir da wichtig sind die eine große
herausforderung ist ich möchte gerne
dafür sorge tragen dass in dieser
gesellschaft mehr respekt herrscht der
respekt vor jedem und vor jeder ich will
dafür sorge tragen dass jede berufliche
leistung jede lebensleistung anerkannt
wird und für mich hat das etwas damit zu
tun dass anerkennung gilt auch für die
leistung die jetzt in dieser krise
erneut als systemrelevant erkannt worden
sind und deshalb will ich ihm das sagen
die lebensmittel verkäuferin der
paketbote die altenpflegerin der
krankenpfleger sie und viele weitere
haben in dieser krise zurecht
anerkennung bekommen und beifall
erhalten das muss aber auch nach der
korona krise noch ein prinzip unseres
land sagen und
auch das gilt anerkennen sich richtig ja
wir haben wahlkampf und was man so olaf
scholz in dieser rede lassen muss
spektakulär und message wie das und
sagen ihr kommunikations jeder satz den
der bundestag sagt ist den einklang mit
dem was er ist in den letzten jahren
gemacht hat wofür die spd gestanden hat
die und lassen was er auf seinen beinahe
kann ankündigt ist diese rede stolz ist
quasi ein animiertes wahlplakat viel
besser kann man das aus spd sicht kaum
810 millionen das heißt ja übersetzt
auch das sind sehr sehr viele und das
sagt etwas über das gehaltsniveau in
diesem lande und das sagt warum die
forderung so wichtig es für ein gutes
miteinander in unserer gesellschaft für
mich bedeutet das aber auch dass wir uns
nicht auf mindestlöhne beschränken
dürfen sondern auch an anderer stelle
dafür sorgen müssen dass es besser läuft
so wie wir das jetzt in vielen anläufen
hingekriegt haben dass endlich in der
fleischindustrie normale arbeitsverträge
abgeschlossen werden das war lange
überfällig wir haben es durchgesetzt
meine damen und herren
deshalb ist es richtig dass wir uns in
vielen anläufen darum bemüht haben dass
endlich in der altenpflege besser
gezahlt wird und dass wir es jetzt
hingekriegt haben ein gesetz zu
beschließen dem drin steht ab dem
nächsten sommer dürfen
pflegeeinrichtungen nur gemäß tarif
bezahlen wenn sie bei der kasse
abrechnen wollen das ist ein erster
schritt dem viele weitere folgen müssen
für diese arbeit
die zweite große herausforderung die wir
in unserer gesellschaft bewältigt müssen
wenn wir an die 20er jahre denken das
ist aber auch die aufgabe dafür zu
sorgen dass wir in zehn 20 und 30 jahren
noch gute arbeitsplätze haben viele
bürgerinnen bürger sind sich nicht so
sicher ob das wohl so ausgehen wird sie
haben sorge und sie schauen sich in um
wenn der welt und stellen fest dass
anders als vor vielen jahrzehnten ist
doch so ist das auf dieser welt vielen
ähnliches können wie wir es sind
milliarden im wieder aufgestiegen asien
es werden viele seinen afrika und dem
süden amerikas was gutes für die welt
aber was ja die anforderung für uns und
unser land richtig formuliert wir müssen
technologisch da vorne bei sein wir
müssen vorne anstehen wenn es darum geht
wirtschaftlich an der spitze mit auf dem
weltmarkt tätig zu sein und dafür müssen
wir uns jetzt einsetzen wir brauchen
technologischen fortschritt für
deutschland und eine leistungsfähige
industrie auch in der zukunft
buch der arbeitsplätze gute
arbeitsplätze
wie wird es aber nur geben wenn wir
gleichzeitig schaffen den
menschengemachten klimawandel
aufzuhalten
und das ist für mich die ganz große
herausforderung vor der wir stehen und
bei der wir jetzt notwendigen das ist
die ganz entscheidende frage die so
viele menschen umtreibt olaf scholz sagt
einstieg wir werben gute arbeits
allerdings muss dann haben wenn wir den
klimawandel aufhalten
man könnte es aber auch durchaus anders
vom argumentieren wir werden den
klimawandel nur aufhalten wenn wir gute
arbeitswelt haben wenn wir weiter
wohlstand aufrecht erhalten in diesem
land wenn wir uns in die
industrialisieren und unsere wirtschaft
kaputt machen bevor wir den klimawandel
überhaupt gesiegt haben genau hier wird
in den letzten tagen des wahlkampfs die
hinten haben wir gesagt verlauf wenn man
bedenkt dass 250 jahre
industriegeschichte darauf beruhen dass
wir kohle gas und öl einsetzen und
deshalb sage ich das darf man nicht
unterschätzen aber weil es eine so große
aufgabe ist und weil wir sie schaffen
können hier in deutschland müssen sie
jetzt anfangen und ihr die notwendigen
entscheidungen treffen
der sehr ideologische worte wenig
praktischen ich muss hier ganz klar
sagen deutschland macht das weltklima
nicht alleine und das würde ich mir
manchmal diesen reden mehr wünschen auch
darauf hinzuweisen zum beispiel in china
wird fast wöchentlich ein kohlekraftwerk
eröffnet der machen wir den kohl auch
nicht mehr solche alternative für die
ausbleibende nutzung der
kohleverstromung werden wir zusätzlichen
strom aus erneuerbaren quellen aus
windkraft auf hoher see an land und der
sonne nutzen müssen aber für das was die
industrie vor hat brauchen wir noch viel
mehr strom wer spricht mit der
stahlindustrie wer spricht mit der
chemieindustrie wir haben er spricht mit
dem die zement herstellen da spricht mit
der automobilindustrie den zulieferern
mit dem maschinenbau mit all den
industrien und wirtschaftszweigen die in
deutschland so wichtig sind er weiß dass
sie dass sie einen klaren plan haben was
zu tun ist dass sie milliardenschwere
investitionen vorhaben dass sie genau
wissen wie sie das hinkriegen
klimaneutral zu wirtschaften das ist der
unterschied zu ihnen die industrie weiß
mehr als sie von der afg die weiß wieder
weg geht
aber sie sagen was wir dazu brauchen ist
strom strom aus windkraft aus sonne
wasserstoff und ein leistungsfähiges
stromnetz und deshalb müssen wir die
ausbauziele hoch setzen die
chemieindustrie hat uns gesagt sie wird
2050 so viel strom verbrauchen wie
deutschland heute insgesamt die
stahlindustrie braucht entsprechend mehr
strom alles aus windkraft sonne und bei
der nutzung von wasserstoff und das ist
die aufgabe die wir jetzt zustande
bringen müssen indem wir jetzt die
ausbauziele für 2045 festlegen indem wir
jetzt festlegen dass wir entsprechend
das stromnetz ertüchtigen und in dem wir
alle gesetze ändern im nächsten jahr
damit die dinge rechtzeitig fertig
werden können eine windkraft anlage zu
genehmigen deutschland darf nicht mehr
sechs jahre dauern das muss den sechs
monaten gehen meine damen und herren
klimaschutz das ist jetzt industrie
politik und deshalb muss es darum gehen
dass wir mit der industrie zusammen
diese große herausforderung bewältigen
klimaschutz ist auch eine politik die
die industrie will sie hat die pläne sie
weiß wie das geht wir müssen unseren
beitrag dazu leisten damit das
funktioniert und deshalb bin ich dafür
dass wir diese große aufgabe anpacken es
ist wichtig für den wohlstand unseres
landes und die zukunft der
bundesrepublik deutschland
vielleicht noch eine bemerkung der immer
auf einen einwand der immer kommt zb aus
ihren reihen aber auch von anderen da
wird gesagt was bringt das wenn wir das
hier in deutschland machen wir sind ja
nur ein kleiner teil der welt und wenn
wir das hier machen dann hat das ja gar
keine auswirkungen auf andere orte der
welt das ist aber falsch denn
natürlich werden wir niemals
die länder asiens afrikas und im süden
amerika davon abbringen können den
gleichen wohlstand haben zu wollen wie
wir das s steht hinzu und sie tun alles
dafür dass ihnen das möglich ist aber
was wir können mit unseren ingenieuren
und mit unserer industrie mit unserer
wirtschaftskraft die technologien
entwickeln die für die ganze welt eine
alternative sind zu den fossilen
ressourcen die heute genutzt werden und
genau diese aufgabe müssen wir annehmen
wir haben natürlich ist das genau die
chance die wir haben und die
herausforderungen die stütze der wir
stehen die frage ist nur wie viel zeit
hat die deutsche wirtschaft dafür bei
den klimazielen geht es nicht darum dass
wir uns grundsätzlich alles einig dann
sind das wir erreicht werden mussten die
frage ist wann müssen sie erreicht
werden und da kann man durchaus sagen
dass der zeitrahmen der gesetze so
ambitioniert ist dass er der deutschen
wirtschaft schadet und der deutschen
produktivität und innovationen in
wohlstand schadet bevor neuen
technologie überhaupt entwickelt werden
können da drückt olaf scholz sich drum
herum gezogen man braucht nicht mehr
streuen das ist eine bedrohung für den
wirtschaftsstandort deutschland eine
weitere von der cdu csu geführte
bundesregierung würde deutschland
wohlstand und arbeitsplätze kosten
meine damen und herren wir
brauchen respekt in unserer gesellschaft
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die zukunft
uns gelingt dass die 20er jahre einen
aufbruch werden die sicherstellen dass
wir in zehn 20 30 jahren noch gute
arbeitsplätze haben und dass wir den
menschengemachten klimawandel aufhalten
können aber wir müssen auch gut
verstehen dass wir nicht alleine sind
auf der welt sondern dass wir nur
gemeinsam mit unseren freundinnen und
freunden in europa eine perspektive
haben in der künftigen welt gut zurecht
kommen zu können das zu verteidigen was
uns wichtig ist an rechtsstaatlichkeit
an demokratie an sozialer
marktwirtschaft und deshalb will ich
hier an dieser stelle noch einmal
bekennen ein weiterer fortschritt für
europa ist das wichtigste nationale
anliegen dass wir in deutschland haben
nur mit der europäischen union gemeinsam
werden wir in einer welt die um die
mitte dieses jahrhunderts zehn
milliarden einwohner hat noch relevant
seien noch mitbestimmen können noch
entscheiden können wie unser leben sich
entwickeln soll und darum muss
deutschland die aufgabe wahrnehmen dafür
zu sorgen dass die europäische union
gelingt und wir eine bessere europäische
union bekommen
deutschland ist das große land in der
mitte der europäischen union wir sind
die die nicht am rande stehen können
schlecht gelaunte kommentare zu den
plänen der anderen abgeben und irgendwie
letztendlich das spiel spielen dass man
hierzulande den fernsehkameras mitteilt
was man alles in brüssel erreichen will
dort freundlich verhandelt hinterher
zurück geht und sagt wie man es allen
anderen gezeigt hat wir müssen das
anders machen wir müssen das land sein
das sich verantwortlich fühlt für diesen
gemeinsamen fortschritt und auch
verhindert dass es eine spaltung gibt
zwischen nord und süd und west und ost
in europa sondern dass die weitere
integration europas gelingt das ist die
große herausforderung das ist die große
aufgabe die wir haben und das wollen wir
gemeinsam hinkriegen die bürgerinnen und
bürger dieses landes dieser deutsche
bundestag und die künftige
bundesregierung die
weitere integration europas soll gelegen
sagt olaf scholz da muss man für unsere
zuschauer sicher sein dass das aus spd
sich da ist es gemeinschaften von
schulter das ist die integration von
europa wie man sie bei den
sozialdemokraten meint heißt auf gut
deutsch die zahlen in zukunft für die
schulden die in frankreich oder italien
gemacht werden klingt schön ist aber
wirtschaftspolitisch hoch umstritten und
für uns ist vermutlich hoch teuersten
zusammen aber die so unverzichtbar ist
das galt und das gilt auch in zukunft
und für mich bedeutet das auch dass wir
alles dafür tun müssen dass wir unsere
verteidigungsanstrengungen auch gut
gewährleisten können deshalb bin ich
froh dass in dieser legislaturperiode
die schlechte zeit für die bundeswehr
die begonnen hat bei einer schwarz
gelben koalition es tut mir leid das
sagen zu müssen dass die endlich zu ende
gegangen es dass der bundeswehr haushalt
die größten steigerung in den letzten
jahren gekriegt hat das war richtig so
und diesen weg werden wir weiter
beschreiten meine damen
wir werden auch in zukunft das will ich
an dieser stelle sagen
weiter entscheidungen treffen müssen und
im rahmen der ehrung im rahmen der nato
mit auf grundlage von entscheidender
vereinten nationen dass wir soldaten im
ausland einsetzen und ich finde dass die
entwicklung in afghanistan ein anders
dafür gibt jeweils zu diskutieren was
man macht und was richtig ist aber es
muss dabei bleiben dass wir verstehen
dass wir nicht alleine sind sondern dass
wir mit den anderen zusammen für frieden
und sicherheit in der welt sorgen müssen
und das wird auch in zukunft weiter eine
aufgabe sein
[Applaus]
in dem sinne da wieder wir auch schon
bei der kanzler wie sich klassische
afghanistan schönrederei wir müssen auch
weiter sehen wie mein verdienst und
stabilität in der welt wenige tage und
jetzt nach wie man das land afghanistan
nach 20 jahren ein sechs wochen größte
wie nie zuvor an die schlimmsten
islamistengruppe der welt ausgehängt
kann wie es bei widerstandslos
kapituliert hat er eindeutig war sie mit
weißem faden abgereist ist das ist schon
ein politisches schönheit kaum noch in
westeuropa haben die bürgerinnen und
bürger haben jetzt das wort ein aufbruch
ist möglich und ich hoffe und ich bin
sicher er wird gelegt schönen dunk
[Musik]